kaputt gespart und aus schleis gefahren
unsere bundeswehr jeder wusste es viele
wollten es nicht wahrhaben bis vladimir
putin die ukraine über viele aber die
zeiten zu wenden in denen es sich
durchaus bequem gemacht hat das ist
knifflig die rhetorischen saalschlachten
der parteien um auf um und nachrüstung
beweisen es derweil die ukraine
tagtäglich um hilfe ruft
100 milliarden und jetzt das dilemma der
bundeswehr jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst zugeschaltet ist general egon
ramms sind seiner aktiven zeit einer der
ranghöchsten deutschen soldaten in der
nato sönke neitzel ist bei uns professor
für militärgeschichte an der universität
potsdam
im studio begrüße ich eva quadbeck
stellvertretende chefredakteurin und
leiterin der hauptstadt redaktion des
redaktions netzwerks deutschland rn die
und markus kainz auch bei uns von der
forschungsgruppe sicherheitspolitik der
stiftung wissenschaft und politik
herr neitzel was machen wir denn jetzt
eigentlich mit den 100 milliarden geld
scheint ja wirklich nicht glücklich zu
machen
naja die 100 milliarden sind glaube ich
schon ein erster wichtiger schritt um
die bundeswehr wieder einsatzbereit zu
machen aber natürlich ist jedem klar
dass 100 milliarden allein den
investitionsstau nicht aufheben aber
jede ist jede institution hat er
natürlich mehr geld aber ich glaube
diese 100 milliarden sind ein wort und
richtig eingesetzt werden sie glaube ich
die bundeswehr schon in zwei drei jahren
in einen anderen zustand versetzen auch
dann wird es noch sachen zu kritisieren
geben aber es ist ein einen schub und
einen anschub und jetzt kommt es darauf
an dass diese 109 jahren nicht nur ein
strohfeuer sind oder dass sie richtig
investiert sind dass die zeit meinte
auch dann heißt die bundeswehr
strukturell fit für die zukunft zu
machen richtig investieren herr ramm das
heißt ja dass die bundeswehr ertüchtigt
werden muss wie wird diese ertüchtigung
eigentlich organisiert somit wie im
advent mit wunschzetteln nicht an den
weihnachtsmann sondern an den
bundeskanzler und dann landet auf dem
gabentisch landen flugzeuge panzer
artillerie wie müssen wir uns das
vorstellen
zunächst aber hat die bundeswehr ja eine
konzeption der bundeswehr einen
fähigkeitsprofil der bundeswehr und wir
haben beispielsweise auch beim personal
ja die absicht das personal zu
verstärken auf 203.000 in dem
fähigkeitsprofil ist festgelegt welche
fähigkeiten die bundeswehr bis 2031
erhalten soll oder bekommen soll und die
notwendigen schritte in der ausrüstung
beschaffung neuen wer materials
austausch von alten gegen neuss wer
material ist das was erfolgen muss eine
wunschliste hilft da nicht so wahnsinnig
bei man hat allerdings jetzt schon den
eindruck dass derjenige der den finger
als erster hochhebt dann möglicherweise
als erster mit relativ hohen summen
bedient wird auch das kennen wir von
früheren beschaffungsmaßnahmen frau
quadbeck
flugbahn zu schwertern möchte man da
fast sagen obwohl wir ja auch viele
pflugscharen brauchen teile der bündnis
grünen und der spd können sich mit der
auf und nachrüstung nicht wirklich
anfreunden kann der kanzler denn da
einigkeit schaffen eine einigkeit der
auch dann die union zustimmt also in den
letzten zwei bis drei wochen habe ich
niemanden im regierungsviertel getroffen
der mir eine garantie gegeben hat oder
gesagt hat ich bin mir ganz sicher dass
wird kommen weil es hat schon viele
runden gegeben und man hat sich bisher
nicht einigen können wo liegt das
problem
es ist unklar wie diese 100 milliarden
ins grundgesetz geschrieben werden
sollen
ursprünglich war die idee ist wirklich
für die bundeswehr für die streitkräfte
auszugeben diese formulierung wollen die
grünen nicht im grundgesetz haben sie
wollen vielmehr die möglichkeit eröffnen
dass das geld auch noch für
bündnisverteidigung ausgegeben wird das
heißt wir würden anderen staaten helfen
bei der aufrüstung und auch noch für die
cyber abwehr sodass steht im raum und
damit würden so 100 milliarden euro
ziemlich schnell zerbröseln er kam zu
einer sinnvollen beschaffung gehört ja
auch eine sinnvolle strategie
besonders jetzt wegen der bedrohung
durch russland wie sieht die aus was
kann man dazu sagen also der
bundeskanzler hat am 27 februar in
seiner begründung eigentlich mit einem
einzigen wort gesagt und das wort war
wehrhaftigkeit an bord was ich aus dem
sport aus dem mund des bundeskanzlers so
nicht erwartet hätte was er
wahrscheinlich auch vor dem 27 februar
lange nicht verwendet hat es geht darum
die bundeswehr im verbund der nato
wieder für bündnis und
landesverteidigung ausrichten man muss
hier noch mal rein dass die der
schwerpunkt der bundeswehr in der nato
mit der nato in den letzten 120 25
jahren ja ganz woanders gelegen hatte
mich im bereich der auslandseinsätze vor
allen dingen afghanistan als bekannteste
auslandseinsatz kugelmann auch
hinzufügen und dieses pendel ist ja
spätestens 2014 wieder zurück
geschwungen das paar bereits erkennbar
und diese entwicklung rückwärts zur
bündnisverteidigung
ist jetzt radikal beschleunigt und
verstärkt worden und die nato hatte ende
juni ihre nieren gipfel auf dem sie das
neue strategische konzept verabschieden
wird und da wird diese priorisierung
wahrscheinlich ganz andere die
festgelegt werden und dann abgeleitet
auch für die bundeswehr für den nächsten
jahre also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass ein deutlicher
verteidigungspolitiker von primaten
bündnis und landesverteidigung nachdem
russland die ukraine im nächsten jahren
zumindest abweichen wird darf ich sagen
der kanzler hat das immer wieder in
einem anderen zusammenhang benutzen ich
würde es darum ging die demokratie zu
ertüchtigen da wird ja auch immer von
der wehrhaften demokratie gesprochen und
nachdem man nun die erkenntnis hat dass
wir auch einen systemischen konflikt
haben nämlich den autoritären gegen den
demokratischen passt das mit der
wehrhaftigkeit eben auch sehr gut da
rein und deshalb ist diese wortwahl auch
nicht zufällig es geht darum die
demokratie zu verteidigen und das im
zweifelsfall dann eben auch mit was
praktisch fühlen das war das glaube ich
möchte eine anmerkung machen zu dem was
er gesagt hat er sprach von 2014 nicht
sprechen was diesen umschalten der nato
auf landes- und bündnisverteidigung
fahren das bündnis verteidigung angeht
spreche ich vom 2010 damals wurde das so
genannte neue strategische konzept der
nato veröffentlicht auf dem gipfel in
dieser bonn und dabei wurde dann auch
gesagt dass bündnisverteidigung für den
gleichen stellenwert hat die die
internationalen einsätze deutschland hat
genau ein jahr später andersrum
entschieden und auch der weckruf von
2014 ist zwar euch sage mal verbal
gehört worden aber konsequenzen hat man
insofern nicht daraus gezogen dass man
bereits zu diesem zeitpunkt angefangen
hätte nachhaltige erhöhung des
verteidigungshaushalts zu machen und die
bundeswehr wieder so auszurüsten dass
sie in der lage wäre zumindest diesen
teil auftrag durchzuführen also
landesverteidigung heißt wie der name
sagt das eigene land zu verteidigen es
gibt kaum
militärexperten experten die sagen
würden dass die bundeswehr im moment in
der lage wäre das eigene land zu
verteidigen herr neitzel ist das
eigentlich nie aufgefallen diese
entwicklung denn worüber geräten das
wussten wir auch schon vor dem 24
februar nur hat es da offenbar wenig
leute guckt
ja also herr absatz schon angedeutet
wenn wir zu zählen neben zu 14 also
natürlich sind diese dinge bekannt
gewesen und wenn wir mal an die presse
denken gerade nach 214 und wird sagen zu
14 15 hat die bundeswehr den tiefstand
ihrer einsatzbereitschaft erreicht da
ist es ja auch bereit in der presse
diskutiert worden was die panzer nicht
fallen die flugzeuge nicht fliegen das
interessante und sie haben es in ihrer
eben angedeutet ist das hat niemand
gejuckt und warum hat es niemand gemocht
weil niemand davon ausging dass ein
panzergrenadierbataillon und seinen puma
schützenpanzern wirklich in die schlacht
ziehen muss also ja es gab probleme mit
diesen neuen schützenpanzer mit anderen
gerät das war auch alles irgendwie ein
bisschen misslich wenn denn der spiegel
oder ich weiß nicht wer hier bei phoenix
darüber berichtet wurde aber letztlich
ist er die frage was wollte man mit der
bundeswehr und ich glaube dass es
völlig klar war dass es so ein und so
ein konsens herrschte in berlin so was
wie afghanistan also dass wir kämpfen
müssen das darf uns nie wieder passieren
möglichst nie wieder passieren und wenn
sie einem eine bundeswehr haben
kampftruppen haben die nie kämpfen
müssen dann ja dann kann man es ja
wissen diskutieren über
einsatzbereitschaft aber die vorstellung
können mit diesem streitkräften wirklich
in den einsatz zu also in den
kampfeinsatz zu gehen wenn ein großes
gefecht das war nicht daran das ist ja
auch in der bundeswehr nicht wirklich
dagewesen nicht wir haben zwar eine
konzeption der bundeswehr die sogenannte
bühler armee nicht mit drei divisionen
bis 2032 aber wer hat dann wirklich
geglaubt mit diesem division je kämpfen
zu müssen und das ist glaube ich denn
das erwachen des 24 februar dass auch
viele auch in der bundeswehr ich nehme
ich gar nicht aus sich gar nicht
vorstellen können dass es zu einem
solchen krieg kommt und jetzt april
april es eben doch ein szenario das
vielleicht eine bundesliga damals in
einen krieg ziehen muss und nicht nur
den krieg spielt sondern ihnen führen
muss und dieses heraus deklinieren des
krieges aus dem referenzlabor politik
ist man sagt uns sachen verantwortlich
das ja dass sich niemand wirklich um die
um die einsatzfähigkeit und die wirkung
von reformmaßnahmen die wirkung von
rüstungs wassern gekümmert hat das war
egal es geht bei dieser frage aber ja
nicht nur um die material ausstattung
und die ausrüstung heran wie war das
denn zu ihrer aktiven zeit sie waren ja
kommandeur auf ganz verschiedenen ebenen
von major bis später zum general war die
bundeswehr oder waren die soldaten dann
die überhaupt in der lage in einem
solchen fall wenn der wie jetzt schon
vor 10 oder 20 jahren eingetreten wäre
wirklich
effektiv das land und das bündnis zu
verteidigen
also aus der rückschau raus war ich ja
21 jahre lang das was man einen kalten
krieger nennt also im kalten krieg auch
geführt und die verbände und einheiten
damals im kalten krieg waren auf diesen
einsatz vorbereitet und wir haben diesen
einsatz auch in übungen entsprechend
geübt einschließlich der tatsache dass
wir in unsere gdp räume gegangen sind
diese erkundet haben dort die stellung
vorbereitet haben oder festgelegt werden
wo die stellung liegen das ganze geld
auch noch bis ich würde mal sagen etwa
2000 damals hat man auch noch wert
darauf gelegt dass die streitkräfte
sowohl internationale einsätze also
damals vor auf dem balkan konnten und
gleichzeitig mit denselben streitkräften
auch die landesverteidigung damals
geführt werden konnte schon die frage
den unterschied festlegen was ist landes
und was ist bündnisverteidigung war dann
schon eine netto erster etwas
schwieriger schritt und der größte
fehler ist nach meinem dafürhalten
diesbezüglich gemacht worden was man im
jahr 2011 die entscheidung getroffen hat
sich ausschließlich auf die
internationalen einsätze zu
konzentrieren und das ist der fehler
gewesen der hinter zu den folgen geführt
hat die gerade von ihnen und auch von
professor entsprechen beschrieben worden
sind jetzt ist ihnen dieser zeit
wahrscheinlich noch ein anderer fehler
gemacht worden der die erosion der
bundeswehr möglicherweise mit
beschleunigt hat nämlich die aussetzung
der wehrpflicht wir hatten darum die 370
tausend soldaten jetzt ins unter 200.000
die meisten sagen das reicht überhaupt
nicht aus diese zahl der soldaten
soldatinnen soldaten in der bundeswehr
selbst wenn viele
kampftechniken heute auch personal
sparen würden die wehrpflicht ist ja nur
ausgesetzt sie ist nicht abgeschafft ist
das eine option darüber noch einmal
nachzudenken also die debatte ist ja
dann genau in diesem zusammenhang wieder
aufgekommen aber die erkenntnis stand
heute ist dass es nicht sehr viel helfen
würde wenn man jetzt
junge wehrpflichtige reinholen würde die
nicht in der lage sind das hoch
technische gerät zu bedienen und
außerdem haben wir auch gar nicht genug
gerät um eben die soldaten daran
auszubilden und dafür zu sorgen dass man
dann ja neue panzer brigaden aufstellt
also das wäre im moment nicht sinnvoll
dass das zu machen das ist vielleicht
dann mal eine debatte die man in der
zukunft noch mal führen kann und in dem
moment in dem deutschland natürlich in
einen kriegerischen konflikt tatsächlich
verwickelt wäre wäre die wehrpflicht
sicherlich sehr schnell wieder
eingeführt deshalb ist sie auch nur
ausgesetzt aber aktuell gibt es keinen
wirklichen keine wirkliche verwendung
wenn man die jungen menschen jetzt
einziehen würde das müsste auch erst die
strukturen müssten erst einmal aufgebaut
werden und dann könnte man sagen wo es
sinnvoll wäre sie einzusetzen die frage
ob das politisch
durchsetzbar ist auch das ja auch die
frage ich kenne die argumente auch sie
wollen mich nicht wirklich überzeugen
ich finde ein interessantes modell das
eines landes was gerade auf der schwelle
der nato ist wie zb finnland wo wir
sehen wo wir eine vergleichsweise kleine
armee haben über glaube wir sind gerade
bei 28 29.000 man aber dann mit der
fähigkeit im krisenfall aufzuwachsen
wenn ich im kopf habe bis zu 900.000 an
mit reservisten freiwilligen und andere
mehr und ich glaube das wäre doch ein
interessantes modell mit dem mehr als
ausländer setzen müssen weil wenn die in
die sicherheitslage auf absehbare zeit
zumindest so weit gucken können wissen
die 25 jahren passiert sich nicht
verändern wird und wir vor der frage
stehen wie wollen wir denn sicherheit
organisieren nicht nur als politischer
politische aufgabe und militärischer
aufgaben sondern ganz bewusst als
gesellschaftliche aufgabe
ich will jetzt das modell nicht eins zu
eins nach aber ich glaube dann werden
wir solche fragen genau diskutieren das
heißt nicht dass jetzt genau das problem
finden hat ja eine andere geschichte die
haben seit jeher eine lange grenze
früher mit der sowjetunion mit russland
sie haben eine traumatische erfahrung
mit den sogenannten winterkrieg 1939 40
gegen die sowjetunion den sie zwar
leidlich den widerstand entgegensetzen
konnten aber das ist natürlich eine ganz
andere erfahrung die man hat um sich
dann hier so militärisch aufzustellen
wie das finnland getan hat was wir
eigentlich im prinzip vorbildhaft ist
eben auch für uns aber können wir das
wirklich so einfach nachvollziehen nach
der schock ist vielleicht ein anderer
gewesen aber ich werde das zentrale die
zentrale determinante der deutschen
bundeswehr ist doch gerade mal 30 jahre
zu ende nämlich der
ausnahmsweise angesprochen also sagen
eine hoch gerade in die lizensierung der
gesellschaft mit verteidigungshaushalten
das darf man heute kaum aussagen von
drei bis fünf prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes in den sechzigern
späten sechziger jahren die haben doch
industrien zu sagen wie wie die
bundesrepublikanische gesellschaft
ausgerichtet war auf einem potenziellen
militär klar aus der anderen setzung mit
dem osten
es gibt viele ärgernisse die die
bundeswehr betreffen eines ist unter
anderem das beschaffungswesen und zwar
schon seit jahrzehnten das hat immer
wieder reformversuche gegeben die alle
irgendwie kann man fast sagen kläglich
gescheitert sind wird da jetzt
wird es gelingen die kurve zu nehmen und
tatsächlich ein beschaffungswesen das im
auftrag der bundeswehr dienen und nicht
irgendwelchen wirtschaftlichen oder
sonstigen interessen
selbst hängt letztlich am politischen
willen und an diesem politischen willen
hat es bisher immer gemangelt also
ich meine ich glaube es gibt fast
niemanden dieser republik der das
wirklich durchblickt
also es ist müssen wir im
gesundheitswesen wenn man die apotheker
fragt oder die leute dass wenn es dem
wohl die ärzte jeder sagt irgendwas
anderes und beschimpften und seine zahl
den anderen da ist es da auch bei der
rüstungsindustrie dem amt in koblenz
oder auch dem ministerium aber das ist
dysfunktional ist es glaube ich
offensichtlich und das also die
niederlande zum beispiel einen anderen
weg gegangen die haben ihr beim bw so
heißt das aufgelöst und es gibt viele
reformvorschläge aber die sind immer
wieder gescheitert also ein gerücht ist
etwa dass frau suter staatssekretärin
suter unter voller leyen daran gehen
wollte und das dann gescheitert ist
andrea nahles hat das dann verhindert
weil man dort eben arbeit arbeitsplätze
sichern wollte in koblenz war das sagen
ihr wahlkreis war und potenzielle spd
wähler und man muss sehen dass die
reform das rüstungs und
beschaffungswesens ein projekt des
gesamten kabinetts ist eine ministerin
allein ist dafür glaube ich zu schwach
und die frage ist ob das
zu erkennen ist es gab ja stimmen die
die froh waren auch in der
rüstungsindustrie dass mit frau
landrecht eine juristin ein erfahrener
jurist innenministerin wurde genau weil
sie sagt dass es ein so komplexes system
ist es gut eine juristin eine erfahrene
juristen als ministerin zu haben was man
jetzt hört ist business as usual man
will an kleinen stellschrauben drehen
also die
ausnahmetatbestände im vergaberecht
nutzen und solche sachen und ansonsten
wird sich überhaupt nichts ändern so ist
mein wissensstand und ob man damit
wirklich die
100 milliarden wirklich sinnvoll
ausgegeben bekommt würde ich ganz stark
bezweifeln denn nach wie vor sehr ein
zentrales problem der bundeswehr die
verantwortung dass die fusion es ist
keiner für irgendwas verantwortlich und
ein inspekteur des heeres es letztlich
nur für die ausbildung verantwortlich
aber nicht dafür das material und
personal und irgendwann wird unsere
general meist sagen wo sind deine
regionen wo sind die brigaden die wir
noch brauchen und er wird sagen ja ich
bin dafür bin ich verantwortlich und das
kann man zum spielen und daran müsste
aus meiner sicht und es sind viele
andere auch dieser ansicht etwas
geändert werden über die details kann
man reden und streiten da gibt's ja auch
unterschiedliche modelle aber mir
scheint es so zu sein dass die
ministerin jetzt ja in der öffentlichen
kritik ist und dass sie von reformplänen
so sie je hatte abstand genommen hat und
das erinnert mich sehr stark auch an das
was sagt ak gemacht hat auch da war es
ja so dass man gehofft hat dass sie
dieses rüstungs wesen angeht und auch
sie dasselbe argument wieland recht im
laufenden betrieb kann man sagen hier
zähle ich die pferde wechseln wir können
es nicht verändern und man hat sich nur
für kleine reform entschieden und wir
sind nicht wirklich vorangekommen in den
letzten 20 jahren wir letztlich nicht
also da muss mehr passieren und deshalb
letztlich wieder von olaf scholz ab von
den politischen druck heran
also ich möchte dir eine aussage von der
pflichten hinsichtlich des politischen
drucks der erforderlich ist um dieses zu
erreichen
aber man muss diese dieses thema angehen
oder muss diesen versuch einfach wagen
weil wenn man da stehen dort wo man
heute stehen bleibt dann muss ich
zugeben werden die 100 milliarden
möglicherweise nicht in einem
vorgeschriebenen der absehbaren zeitraum
abfließen das ist der eine teil dabei
möglicherweise werden dann auch aus lust
und laune dinge geschafft die
tatsächlich nicht den wirklichen bedarf
der bundeswehr darstellen aber ich
möchte noch zwei andere punkte an reißen
wir haben ja selber das vergaberecht und
das ist richtig das thema muss im
gesamten kabinett angefasst werden
finanzminister wirtschaftsminister
justizminister um dieses vergaberecht
möglicherweise anzupassen und wir haben
zusätzliche neben dem vergaberecht das
europäische vergaberecht das heißt
abgestimmten höhe muss alles im
europäischen bereich ausgeschrieben
werden und das führt dann dazu dass die
sachen sich dann noch weiter verzögern
oder aufs unendliche verzögern andere
länder machen das geschickt da andere
europäische länder machen das geschick
dann nämlich gehen in dem die schlicht
und einfach sagen das berührt
sicherheitsinteressen und wenn
sicherheitsinteressen berührt sind
greift das europäische vergaberecht
nicht das wäre zum beispiel ein erster
schritt die in deutschland als getreue
europäer vielleicht auch mal gehen
sollte um auf diese art und weise dinge
zu beschleunigen zweiter aussage
die gemacht worden ist war das thema
material verantwortung die material
verantwortung wurde auch wieder 2011 das
sind sie die interessante entscheidung
gefällt worden anders beiden bewegen
koblenz übergeben die material
verantwortung juristische verantwortung
nach vorher war den inspekteuren der
teilstreitkräfte aus dem grund hatten
die ein interesse daran dass ihr
material einsatzbereit war ob der leiter
des beiden bewegen koblenz daran
interessiert dann mache ich zumindest
mal vorsichtig und fragezeichen goodbye
eine bd ist das beschaffungsamt
quadbeck wir haben jetzt von
verschiedenen minister ministerin
gesprochen die dazu ständig sind aber
man darf ja auch die
wahlkreisabgeordneten und zwar
diejenigen nicht übersehen bei denen
rüstungsbetriebe arbeiten und viele
arbeitsplätze bereitstellen das nicht
nur im beschaffungsamt in koblenz so das
muss ja eine politische entscheidung das
muss eine politische führung gebe das
ist eine führungsentscheidung des
bundeskanzlers zu sein hier gelten keine
partikularen oder lokal interessen
sondern hier sind die interessen der
bundeswehr
vordergründig hat olaf scholz da das
durchsetzungsvermögen das kind ja auch
zum beispiel für die eigene fraktion das
ist ja angesichts der schwäche der
ministerin die wir haben wird er sowieso
das ein oder andere an sich ziehen
müssen um überhaupt die dinge
voranzubringen und wenn man auf das
beschaffungswesen guckt dann sind glaube
ich zwei dinge nötig zum einen ist es
bestimmt wichtig diese behörde zu
modernisieren vielleicht sie einer kur
zu unterziehen wie es seinerzeit
geschehen ist mit frank weise in der
bundesagentur für arbeit ja wo aus dem
amt daneben eine agentur gemacht wurde
was dann auch tatsächlich zur
effizienteren strukturen geführt hat und
dass man sich bestimmt auch mal sehr
genau angucken sollte general ramms hat
es gesagt im großen auf das vergabewesen
muss man natürlich auch mal schauen wie
wird denn im kleinen bestellt also für
den alltag der soldaten und nach allem
was ich von den experten höhere die sich
damit befasst haben sind auch die
befehls wege und die
vorschriften was man alles beachten muss
und was weis ich einfache dinge zu
bestellen die sind gigantisch also wenn
man selber für eine einheit etwas
bestellen möchte muss man wird erst mal
rundum abgefragt wäre das vielleicht
noch braucht und dann werden so viele
vorgaben 8 bis am ende entweder ist ewig
dauert oder dass das was man dann nach
25 verschiedenen vorgaben hat gar nicht
mehr so bestellen kann und dann muss es
erstmal gebaut werden für die bundeswehr
das sind so diese probleme das auch
alles sich verzögert und alles so viel
teurer wird und da muss man noch nicht
mal sagen dass die menschen die da
sitzen nicht fähig werden sondern es ist
wie gesagt die struktur des amtes selbst
und es ist sind diese merkwürdigen
vorschriften und wenn natürlich dann
ja ein führer bis zur halskrause voll
ist mit vorschriften die am kopf hat
bevor er was tun kann dann kann es auch
nicht funktionieren also diese
selbstblockade die es im moment immer
noch gibt ich würde gerne noch auf einen
anderen aspekt in dem zusammenhang
kommen herr kaim wir befinden uns gott
sei dank nicht im verteidigungsfall hier
in deutschland aber wir sind natürlich
durch den krieg gegen die ukraine auch
massiv mit der frage material in diesem
krieg konfrontiert
dauerbrenner ist schwere waffen soll man
die dorthin liefern da gibt es ja auch
politische diskussionen
soll die denn jetzt geliefert werden
diese schweren waffen können wir die
überhaupt liefern haben wir da genügend
material jetzt wie bei den 50 g panzern
wollen wir das überhaupt machen was ist
da im moment bei dieser frage wie wir
mit dem material das in der bundeswehr
je knapp ist oder in nato-verbänden
konzentriert die sonde mit dieser frage
eigentlich umgehen und was bedeutet das
konkret also ich finde sie haben die
beschlüsse über soviel gesagt können und
wollen und das feld nicht und nicht
zwingend aufeinander und in den letzten
tagen sind ja doch die zweifel an dem
wollen entstanden welche bereitschaft
ein bild im engagement in welchem tempo
die bundesregierung die ringtausch
vorbereitet waffen die vor an die
ukraine vorbereitet da mag man auch im
detail bei 1
panzer war einzelne haubitzen streiten
aber der eindruck entstanden ist gerade
bei osteuropäischen verbündeten ist doch
fragwürdig so dass viel von dem momentum
oder von der reputation die der
bundeskanzler seit dem 27 februar wieder
erworben hatte gerade in den
osteuropäischen hauptstädten die sich
von deutschland den letzten jahren wenig
gehört gefühlt haben in fragen der
russland-politik das kleintier doch
wieder zu verpuffen und das können im da
müsste man jetzt in einzelne
waffensysteme gehen also ich glaube da
gibt es durchaus dort stände und von dem
was wir in den monaten erlebt haben
jetzt drei monaten eine zusagen
salamitaktik die bundesregierung dass
die immer anfing mit wir können nicht
weil wir müssen an der bundes und
landesverteidigung festhalten um dann
wenige tage später zu signalisieren man
solle doch bereit unter bestimmten
umständen in bestimmter konstellation
waffen abzugeben und das führt doch den
eindruck dass jetzt bestimmte
waffensysteme in ergänzt überblicke dass
doch mehr noch zu verdienen ist als als
ist anfangs ihm erklingt
herbst hofft dass vielleicht noch mal
unterstützen also ich bin sehr
überrascht gewesen dass nach den 27
februar also nach der rede zur
zeitenwende ja durch die industrie
plötzlich bekannt gegeben worden ist das
beispielsweise bei der flensburger
fahrzeugbau gesellschaft doch
soundsoviel 100 kettenfahrzeuge und
panzer stehen das chaos maffei wegmann
nach über welche verfügt jetzt auch und
plötzlich in den letzten tagen irgendwo
noch neue neue alte muss ich jetzt sagen
leopard 2 auf den firmen beständen sind
und es muss nicht verwundern in jeder
beziehung verwundern dass man sich nicht
zu anfang relativ schnell 27 28 29
februar zusammen gesetzt hat oder
einfach mal diese bestände
zusammengetragen hat um auf diese art
und weise zu die frage zu stellen was
haben wir die zweite frage werden
gewesen was brauchen wir bei der
bundeswehr die bundeswehr braucht auch
kampfpanzer leopard 2 1 bei der firma
verstehen welche um das ist schon auch
eine interessante feststellung die man
so nebenbei machen kann und das gleiche
gilt auch für die schützenpanzer maler
die panzerhaubitzen ja wir haben ein
paar mehr als wir im soll bestand haben
sollten aber es wäre gut wenn man für
reserven logistische reserven
beziehungsweise instandsetzungs reserven
auch da gewisse vorräte hätte also
prioritäten setzen wäre der eine teil
gewesen zusammentragen was da ist und
dieses ganze was ich gerade gesagt habe
möchte ich ein bisschen vor dem
hintergrund der heutigen lage in der
ukraine sehen die ukraine steht im
augenblick unter einem mord mäßigen
druck im don was die russen der zielen
gewinne beschießen städte marschieren
vor kreisen städte ein und wir reden
immer noch darüber und haben keine
einzige waffe geliefert und will meinen
kenntnisstand stand jetzt ein donnerstag
also vor einer woche richtig ist gibt es
bisher auch nicht alle einzige
exportgenehmigung und da kann ich nur
sagen donnerwetter wenn wir auf diese
art und weise weitermachen dann werden
wir das vertrauen unserer östlichen
nachbarn in der nato komplett verlieren
und wir sind gerade auf dem besten weg
könnten wir mehr und schneller liefern
ich lasse jetzt mal offen wo wir
ringtausch ist oder direktlieferungen da
gibt es ja auch gewisse hindernisse aber
ist da die
bundesrepublik deutschland ist die
bundesregierung dazu zögerlich es gibt
ja auch vorwürfe an den bundeskanzlern
die spd von seiten der union das wäre
sogar eine verzögerungstaktik weil man
das nicht wirklich will
ja wer da wesentlich mehr möglich und
vor allem schneller möglich
ja und wir sind wieder bei der frage des
politischen willens also herr namens hat
ja auch gesagt natürlich hat die
bundeswehr wenig material und bundeswehr
möchte jetzt lieber ihre panzerhaubitzen
für sich behalten auch die mara und so
weiter aber es ist eine politische
entscheidung und die frage muss doch
nicht darstellen wozu diese sieben
panzerhaubitzen besser eingesetzt ich
weiß nicht in idar oberstein oder in
sennelager oder folgt einem übungsplatz
geraden litauen oder nicht vielleicht
doch in der ukraine also wir haben ja
ist ja nicht so dass die bundesrepublik
deutschland keine keine waffen hat sie
hat eine bundeswehr die hat strukturelle
probleme und noch ausrüstungs probleme
aber es gibt ein kampfpanzer
artilleriegeschütze und so weiter und so
weiter und es ist eine politische
entscheidung diese waffen der ukraine
zur verfügung zu stellen oder wie viel
von diesen waffen und diese entscheidung
muss man jetzt nicht von heute auf
morgen treffen aber man braucht nicht
monate um diese entscheidung zu treffen
und ich kann nur an die positionen von
meiner vorredner
unterstützen es ist einfach ein eiertanz
die bundesregierung hier aufführt den
kein mensch mehr glauben kann also
warum man ewig braucht um diese maria
einsatzbereit zu machen die bei der
industrie noch sind man kann diskutieren
ringtausch mit slowenien das findet
jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht statt weil
die slowenen um so mara gar nicht haben
wollen aber dann kann man immer noch
überlegen sie an die ukraine zu liefern
und auf mich macht das und ich sitze
auch nicht im bundessicherheitsrat aber
den eindruck dass die spd hier auf zeit
spielt das man hofft und mützenich hat
es ja wunderbar jetzt am wochenende im
interview gesagt dass er hofft dass wir
bald ein waffenstillstand an damit wir
uns endlich anderen dingen zuwenden
können und ich glaube das ist teile der
bundesrepublik oder der bundesregierung
sind noch nicht in der realität
angekommen
rams hat ja auch auf die schwierige
militärische lage verwiesen
und man hoffte glaube ich oder hofft
vielleicht immer noch na ja das wird
sich irgendwie lösen da gibt es ein
waffenstillstand dann sind wir
eigentlich irgendwie raus und mit den
ankündigungen auch den gebhard es gibt
ja kaum an waffensystemen was was länger
braucht um einsatzbereit zu sein und
dann sehen wir auch wieder die
bundesverteidigungsministerium werden
sagt damit kann man also
kritische infrastruktur oder zivile
infrastruktur schützen da sage ich nur
na ja also es geht um einen krieg und
diese waffen werden in der regel an der
front eingesetzt und also einer semantik
kann man schon erklären wie sehr vor
allem die spd ringt um die position es
ist kann man auch sagen nachvollziehen
wenn man weiß wo die spd herkommt aber
man muss schon auch mal sehen und was
ist jetzt eigentlich geht dann soll doch
la casta scholz sagen wir helfen der
ukraine nicht dass wir ehrlich er hat
aber gesagt wir werden alles tun um die
ukraine zu unterstützen und diesen
worten lässt scholz keine taten folgen
auch gesagt marta manser können wir dann
ja auch direkt an die ukraine liefern
wenn es hier so wenig haben wollen nur
das geht ja glaub ich garnicht frau
quartett wenn ich das richtig verstanden
aber am wochenende da hat ja die
parlamentarische staatssekretär im
bundesverteidigungsministerium
die welt wissen lassen dass ist
eine angeblich einen nato beschluss gebe
das
kampf- und schützenpanzer also die
wichtigsten panzer waffen westlicher
bauart gar nicht in die ukraine
geliefert werden sollen
ist zwar für viele neu gewesen für mich
ehrlich gesagt auch ist werde vielleicht
auch
nachvollziehbar warum das so ist aber
gibt es diesen beschluss also mir
scheint dass ein weiterer vorgeschobener
grund zu sein und das stützt absolut die
these die leider wahr ist dass
deutschland auf der bremse steht dass
deutschland eigentlich hofft dass dieser
krieg irgendwann zu ende sein wird und
man gekommen ist tatsächlich
schwere waffen in größerem umfang an die
ukraine zu liefern und diese these wird
ja auch dadurch gestützt dass man sehen
kann dass scholz bisher noch nicht nach
kiew gereist ist das ganz offensichtlich
vermeidet er hat selber schon öffentlich
gesagt dass sein es seinem amtseid
entspricht das schaden vom deutschen
volk abzuwenden
die frage ist nur aber da die richtige
strategie hat wenn er meint dass er eben
durch das sie nicht liefern von waffen
was dann aus spd sicht eine nicht
provokation von russland ist schaden vom
deutschen volk abwenden kann also dafür
ist die konfrontation zwischen russland
und dem westen schon viel zu
festgefahren als dass das wirklich eine
gute strategie wäre ja auch wer hat
eskaliert und wer hat die konfiguration
besucht und war ja nicht der westen
gewesen sowieso nicht und wenn man aber
dann nochmal darauf schaut wie er seine
strategie untermauert was ja auch
wirklich seine strategie ist erst in
kiew gefahr makro ist bisher auch nicht
nach kiew gefahren und das während die
beiden die einen normandie format noch
mal auflegen könnten also da gibt es
eben immer diese leise hoffnung dass
deutschland und frankreich dann
diejenigen sein könnten die vielleicht
als
händler für aus für einen verein wie
auch immer gearteten waffenstillstand
oder friedensschluss dastehen könnten
nur wenn man sich die lage anschaut und
eben sieht wie der krieg in der ukraine
eskaliert dann ist diese hoffnung auf
sehr dünnem einfach auch sehr wenig sand
gebaut und funktioniert nicht und
deshalb müsste deutschland sich wirklich
ein rein in die westlichen in die
westlichen mächte und minden denn das
gleiche tun was die osteuropäer tun dass
man sagt alles was man hat wirft man
nach vorne er kein genereller haben
sonst gerade gesagt die situation im don
was ist ja auch nicht kritisch geworden
jetzt für die ukraine hat russland seine
ganze militärmacht konzentriert wir
wissen jetzt hören auch immer wieder was
da wichtig wäre an lieferungen von
waffen gerät bis zur munition
ersatzteilen und logistischen
möglichkeiten was braucht die ukraine
den wirklich um diesen russischen
angriffen inters widerstehen zu können
hatte haben sie da die richtigen waffen
kriegen sie die richtigen waffen auch
aus dem westen geliefert
das kann ich im detail nicht beurteilen
muss ich ja freiwillig einräumen weil
sehr viele bild eine bestimmte waffen
die von gerade bester verbündeter
geheimhaltung unterliegen also vieles
von dem was die usa geliefert haben an
material ist ja nicht öffentlich bekannt
geworden als wir handycam gegen die
hausnummern den finanziellen rahmen ab
die usa sind der im gegensatz zu
deutschland etwas zurückhaltender bei
der öffentlichen debatte ihrer lieferung
da gibt es sehr sehr unter die praktiken
von da muss ich mich damit rausreden so
seien die westlichen banken die von
haben einen signifikanten unterschied
gemacht in den letzten drei monaten das
ist das tolle nach athen drei mal sollte
in diesem kontext im nach wie vor noch
mal betont werden es ist schwer zu
quantifizieren also wir jetzt komme ich
um sehen zu sagen das ist zehn prozent
des ukrainischen widerstandes ausgemacht
oder 20 prozent das kann niemand sagen
aber ich glaube wir gehen weil kohl
recht in der annahme dass die
waffenlieferung gerade von den usa die
abreise früher eingeleitet worden sind
substanziellen sehr umfangreich
signifikante unterschied gemacht haben
und ich glaube dass in kombination das
will ich nicht vertiefen aber sagen auch
noch angedeutet dieses passiert auch die
nach die nachrichtendienstliche
operationen über die wir ja auch nicht
so viel wissen aber die auch manchmal
durchscheint
also die enge kooperation der
amerikanischen geheimdienste mit der
ukraine führen haben glauben die
giganten untertrieb gemacht und das
deutet zumindest an dass es kein
lohnendes unterfangen ist also das ist
jetzt keine verzweiflungstat jetzt hier
jemandem aus politischen gründen noch
waffen hinterher zu werfen ohne
perspektive auf einen sieg oder
zumindest ein paar militärisches patt zu
haben damals ja gerade gesagt hatte
ganz kurz
ich glaube die was man sehen muss ist
dass die östlichen nato- staaten ja ihr
russisches organisches material
geliefert haben und dass die ukraine
dabei ist dieses altmaterial zu
verbrauchen auch ihre eigenen geräte
ihre eigene
ihre eigenen geschütze und
es haben jetzt nochmal bulgarien 9000
tonnen munition geliefert an alters wird
schamoni zitiert russische munition und
was jetzt die die ukraine braucht ist
als sie diesen in diesem krieg verluste
hatten etwa also mindestens 50 prozent
der verluste russlands etwa erleidet
diese geschützen und panzern sowie
cerberus verbaut müssen allmählich vom
westen ersetzt werden mit westlicher
munition sonst geht irgendwann der
ukraine die munition aus weil es für
diese geschütze glaube ich nur in
tschechien eine kleine fabrik gibt und
die die altbestände die die nato-staaten
aufgebraucht sind also die die
westlichen staaten auch deutschland ist
irgendwie in der pflicht wenn der krieg
weitergeht und die ukraine wird ihn nur
weiterführen können wenn dieses alte
gerät vom westen höher für ersetzt wird
was gesagt hat ich würde das gern noch
noch ergänzen mit einer frage ist aber
gerade gesagt die die schwierige
situation der ukraine in bonn bass nur
westliches material das jetzt mit dem
jetzt die verluste aufgefüllt werden
müssen ukrainische soldaten ausgebildet
werden dass es zum teil hoch
kompliziertes gerät es gibt in west ja
übrigens auch die angst dass viele
hochtechnologie waffen den russen in die
hände fallen könnten in diesem krieg was
muss jetzt passieren um die ukraine so
zu ertüchtigen dass sie diese angriffe
im dorf so weit es geht abwehren kann
wenn sie mir erlauben mich wohl noch
polen noch zwei kurze bemerkung aufgrund
der aussagen der parlamentarische
staatssekretärin habe ich mich angesetzt
man habe sehr intensiv recherchiert mit
blick wo die aussage angebliche aus der
nato herkommen und bei der video schalte
die der amerikanische
verteidigungsminister welche das richtig
im kopf habe vorgestern gemacht hat war
gestern gemacht hat ist rausgekommen das
von der amerikanischen seite oder nato
seite her keinen widerspruch gegen die
lieferung der t 72 aus so wenigen aus
der tschechei oder tschechischen
republik oder aus polen gegeben hat von
daher sind panzerlieferung ich sag das
mal ganz einfach nicht verboten erste
aussage zweiter aussagen und panzer
westlichen raum aus stehen wir uns immer
wünschen
ich komme darauf diesen ringtausch von
dem wie immer reden der wird irgendwann
zu ende sein weil dieses ehemalige
sowjetische oder ehemalige russische
material in diesen ländern aufgebraucht
sein wird und dann müssen wir hinterher
liefern wir dürfen die ukraine nicht
ohne logistik nicht ohne versorgung
nicht ohne munition und nicht ohne
waffensysteme stehen lassen wenn wir das
tun ist der krieg in der ukraine zu ende
und ich möchte dazu den ganz einfachen
satz hinzuzufügen hinzufügen die ukraine
verteidigt im augenblick die freiheit
des freien europas in jeder beziehung
und wenn wir den krieg näher uns
anziehen wollen dann sollten wir weiter
nicht liefern wenn wir in fernhalten
wollen dann müssen wir die ukraine mit
allem was wir haben unterstützen
es gibt jetzt eine frage die ja hier mal
auch auftritt und diskutiert wird wo es
läuft eigentlich ende
nicht auch zitiert worden der hofft dass
der krieg bald zu ende ist haben wir
denn eigentlich strategische ziele
definiert wo das hinführen soll wie das
nach bei der lösung des konfliktes
aussehen sollen oder konzentrieren soll
es zu sehen nur darauf
russland möglichst wieder aus dem land
zu werfen die strategischen ziele können
wir ja nur schwer definieren also es
gibt ein strategisches ziel dass der
westen insgesamt definiert wir wollen
keinen dritten weltkrieg wir wollen
keine atomaren schläge und deshalb wird
der ukraine ja zum beispiel auch sich
bewährt dass die nato ihr hilft den
luftraum zu verteidigen das wäre dann so
ein fall wo putin sagen würde so ganz
klarer eingriff in die natur
genauer flugverbotszone umzusetzen und
ansonsten ist es natürlich an der
ukraine selbst zu entscheiden ob sie
bereit ist kompromisse zu machen ob sie
sagt sie will auf jeden fall den status
von 2014 wieder haben und dann wie auch
immer geartete referenten in den
gebieten die putin 2014 besetzt und
annektiert hat oder dass die ukraine
bereit ist das erst mal ruhen zu lassen
die option gibt es ja auch und zu sagen
wir machen den waffenstillstand
sowie die truppen stehen und alles
weitere wird später geregelt aber das
können kann der westen der ukraine nicht
überstülpen weil wir ja auch offiziell
an diesem krieg gar nicht teilnehmen und
deshalb kann das strategische ziel nur
bleiben wir wollen keine eskalation kein
übergreifen auf nato staaten oder scholz
hat ja auch der ukraine versichert es
wird keine vereinbarung die auch immer
mit russland geben über den kopf der
ukraine hinweg
müssten heißt das also wir werden dann
sozusagen uns dem ukrainischen viele
kriegsziel oder der ukrainischen
strategie wohl oder übel anschließen
müssen wir müssen es dann nicht wenn wir
eigene strategische ziele definieren und
ich bin dabei den punkt den sie mit
ihrer frage andeuten das tut die
bundesregierung nicht sie wägt so
minimal telefonie an seinem
sonntagsreden sagt die ukraine deutlich
verlieren russland darf nicht gewinnen
der blick sofort nachfragen was soll das
denn heißen weil der teufel liegt wie
immer noch im detail und aufgrund des
positiven ausgangs der letzten wochen
für die ukraine sind die ist die ukraine
jetzt doch etwas
zuversicht die höher geworden etwas
offensiver geworden und der punkt ist ja
genau den den sie angesprochen haben ist
unser ziel die ukraine dabei zu
unterstützen auf die position von 23
februar zurückzukehren oder sie
akzeptieren wir das was der ukrainische
aussenminister in letzten teilnehmers
gesagt hat verkürzt gesagt woraus die
krim zurück was dem völkerrecht die eine
deutsche position sein müsste ob das
politisch klug ist die ukraine damit so
er zu ermutigen und die die waffen
abzuliefern leben ganz anderen auch das
militärisch überhaupt denkbar ist dass
das jetzt mal außen vor was ich damit
sagen will ich glaube die
bundesregierung kann sich je weiter der
cgi ford schreitet immer weniger leisten
die
bundesrepublikanische nicht halten nebel
zu lassen und auch im sinne eines
gedeihlichen deutsch und kritischen
verhältnisses ist glaube ich dringend
angesagt sich wird den kähnen über die
möglichkeit und auch grenzen der
deutschen unterstützung ins benehmen zu
setzen
wir haben den namen der
verteidigungsministerien hier heute
schon mehrfach in den mund genommen muss
olaf scholz nach dem was jetzt eine
lampe sozusagen auch in offenen flanken
bietet unter ganz unterschiedlichen
aspekten mit ganz unterschiedlichen
fragen muss er sie auswechseln er hat
auf jeden fall das amt falsch besetzt
und sie ist schwer angezählt also zum
einen wie sie da gestanden hat bei dem
thema waffenlieferungen wobei da kann
man noch sagen
gesamtproblem der bundesregierung die
vorwürfe hören nicht auf dass sie sich
nicht richtig ein arbeitet in ihrer
thematik dann kommt noch eine spd
interner lapsus ja dazu das interview
das sie gegeben hat wo sie gemeint hat
die innenministerin sollte jetzt
ministerpräsident in hessen werden und
dann wäre für sie der innenminister
posten frei ja das nur in klammern
gesprochen das hat sie also wirklich
nicht gesagt aber das war das was
dahinter stand und dann natürlich die
permanente kritik an ihr dass sie mit
kam es dann im wüstensand steht da kann
man immer noch sagen das ist auf jeden
fall die kleinste sind und wäre sie eine
gute verteidigungsministerin dann würde
man das vielleicht sogar noch cool
finden dass sie das macht aber vor dem
hinrunden gerecht beurteilt im moment ja
das ist immer also es wird sicherlich
jetzt auf ihren äußerlichkeiten
rumgehackt aber das problem ist
hausgemacht wie gesagt wäre sie eine
wirklich gute verteidigungsministerin
würden diejenigen denen die teams im
wüstensand nicht gefallen würde das
durchwinken und sagen egal sie ist eine
gute verteidigungsministerin und
diejenigen die das sowieso nicht schlimm
finden vielleicht aber sagen ja man kann
sie sich erlauben aber sie kann es sich
eben nicht erlauben
neitzel haben wir haben leider nur noch
etwas mehr als eine minute deswegen ganz
kurze antwort ja auch noch zwei fragen
glauben sie dass belarus auf seiten
russlands eingreift in der nächsten zeit
um den krieg zu entscheiden
es gibt anzeichen dafür auf seiner seite
hat lukaschenko in der vorvergangenen
woche sehr deutlich gemacht dass er
beispielsweise der rhetorik der russen
einen atomschlag zu durchzuführen oder
vergleichbares nicht zustimmen wird war
dafür sein eigenes london angst hat 19
wie lange wird dieser krieg dauern was
schätzen sie ein jetzt mal unabhängig
von der frage ob es zu einem
waffenstillstand ob es zu einem frieden
kommt oder nur zu einem großen konflikt
also dass dieser konflikt quasi nicht
beseitigt wird sondern nur eingefroren
was glauben sie wielange müssen wir bis
zu einem einigermaßen glaube dass ich
glaube dass da gucke ich glaube dass der
konflikt noch viele jahre dauern wird
ich kann mir einen echten frieden in
absehbarer zeit schlicht nicht
vorstellen russland hat noch viel in der
hinterhand die ukraine hat die
unterstützung vielleicht auch nicht
deutschland aber doch der usa und
anderer staaten aber so verwirrt dass
noch viele jahre dauern in
unterschiedlicher intensität
dann bedanke ich mich bei eva quadbeck
bei markus kaim hier im studio bei egon
ramms und bei sinken einzel für die
diskussion live zuschauer am sonntag
vielleicht zunächst morgen christi
himmelfahrt ist keine fixe hunde am
sonntag um 13 uhr das karlsruher
verfassungsgericht moderiert von jörg
schönenborn mit dem titel alternative
sackten leben wir im selben universum
eine diskussion am sitz des
bundesverfassungsgerichts anlass war der
tag des grundgesetzes am 23
jetzt folgt der tag mit thomas bade
darin vor allen dingen der amoklauf an
der grundschule in texas bleiben sie bei
uns
[Musik]